yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
according to x-men apocalypse writer
Simon Kinberg the first cut of the movie
was around two hours 40 minutes long
which means that the whole bunch of
scenes and concepts that didn't make the
final cut including an extended mole
sequence and all of that I'm going to be
looking at in this video of course there
will be spoilers ahead so if you want to
avoid those click here for my spoiler
free review or comeback after you've
seen the movie and as promised I'm going
to be giving away another pack of cool
x-men apocalypse merch on this video to
enter the giveaway you just need to
subscribe and leave a comment about the
deleted scenes or what you'd like to see
in an extended cut of the movie first up
is an extended scene at the shopping
mall which Simon Kinberg has described
as an 80s montage set to music and was
some interesting Easter eggs the movie's
production team located an unused period
mall in Montreal and got permission to
renovate it putting it out with retail
outlets and brands you'd expect to see
in a typical 80s American mall a video
arcade in the mall was refurbished with
vintage machines and rebranded a
spaceport which was the name of the
video arcade where director Bryan Singer
played as a kid the mall scene
culminates in Cyclops Jean Grey Jubilee
and Nightcrawler coming out of a movie
theater after watching Return of the
Jedi that final part is included in the
theatrical release but the rest was cut
as according to the filmmakers it slowed
down the movie too much sophie turner
teased another part of the mole sequence
when she posted a picture of herself as
Jean Grey shopping at the mall with
Cyclops it's a very cool Easter Egg to
the comic book mutants Dazzler who first
appeared in the x-men comics in 1980 and
who has the power to transform sound
waves into light beams and energy the
album Dazzler sounds of light and fury
that Scott Summers is holding actually
appears on the cover of issue 29 of the
comic book Dazzler
and there's another amusing moment in
the record store when Scott picks up an
album featuring Boy George and ask Jean
has anyone ever told you you look like
this
although Jubilees role was cut down in
the final film they did shoot an
important scene at the shopping mall
where she got to use her powers in the
comics Jubilee has the power to produce
explosive balls of energy plasma or
fireworks by the way the shopping mall
itself is an easter egg - how jubilee
discovered her powers in the comics
after running away from a mall security
guard and it's also where she met at the
x-men members including storm rogue
psylocke and Dazzler it's actually
rumored that the deleted scene is
similar to the comics with Jubilee using
her powers and then having to escape
from the mole security using her
gymnastic abilities Nightcrawler
also had some funny scenes at the mall
including a moment where he started
break dancing with a group of kids and
in another funny scene the four mutants
are drinking cold drinks when
Nightcrawler becomes scared as he got an
ice-cream headache but when Scott tells
him not to worry is just a brain freeze
Nightcrawler gets even more frightened
as he thinks his brain is about to
freeze over also hidden in the mole
sequences in a marsh in the 1980s movie
Moscow on the Hudson starring Robin
Williams as the young mutants walk
around Nightcrawler who is new to
America is amazed that ordinary people
don't fear than was mutants Nightcrawler
thinks the mall is a paradise and it
parallels how Robin Williams Russian
character feels when he arrives in
America in the movie Moscow on the
Hudson in the film Williams plays a
Soviet musician in the circus who
defects during a visit to Bloomingdale's
in New York which is doubly interesting
as Nightcrawler
also performed in the circus before he
met the x-men prior to Scotts mantra he
was at the x-mansion with his brother
Alex aka havoc and just before Alex left
was Charles to visit Moira at the CIA
the on-screen brothers filmed a farewell
scene this would have been the last
moment Cyclops shared with his brother
havoc as it was while Cyclops is
returning from the malls that havoc died
during the x-mansion explosion
Bryan Singer has mentioned that Michael
Fassbender filmed a beautiful scene
outdoors which brought tears to the
filmmakers eyes from what singer has
said it sounds like the scene was of
magneto with his polish family
according to singer although the scene
was incredible it just didn't fit in the
overall story in the movie apocalypse
has four horsemen storm Angel Psylocke
and magneto was in an earlier version of
the script apocalypse only had storm
angel and magneto as his three horsemen
and there were no plans at all to
include Psylocke in the movie the
initial script had Charles being
kidnapped by apocalypse with the
intention of counting him as the fourth
Horseman but Kinberg and singer realized
that this wouldn't really work so they
looked through the comic book history of
the various horsemen and thought that
Psylocke was the most intriguing the
filmmakers had actually just met with
Olivia Munn to talk about a pot in
Deadpool and it was when they came
across some fanart of her ass I locked
that they thought she'd be perfect for
the role Olivia Munn's role in the movie
changed again even after she was cast
initially it was announced that she'll
be playing Betsy Braddock who in her
comic book origins story grows up in the
UK Olivia Munn is a huge fan of psylocke
and the characters comic book history
however the filmmakers decided that the
movie with not explore Betsy's life
before she became psylocke for example
her time as a pilot or a model and she
wouldn't have a British accent either
Wolverines cameo could have turned out
quite differently and there were many
versions that were considered including
not having him in the film at all
another option the filmmakers looked at
was having Wolverine appear in the
middle of the movie at which point he
would have taken on a team leader role
to the young x-men
however this route was rejected as it
interfered with Ravens story arc and
other variations didn't seem to work
either
the final cameo during which we see
Wolverine go full-on Berserker mode at
the alkali Lake Weapon X facility turned
out well even if the filmmakers haven't
yet addressed the plot hole of how he
ended up there after mystique disguised
as Stryker pulled him out of the river
at the end of Days of Future past so
guys what do you think about the deleted
scenes and would you like to have seen
any
them in the final cut of the movie as
always I'd love to hear what you've got
to say in the comments below don't
forget to comment and subscribe for your
chance to win this awesome x-men
apocalypse merchandise and you can click
on the gleam link in the video
description below for bonus ways to
enter the giveaway if you enjoyed this
video check out my full Easter Egg guy
to x-men apocalypse and also my full
post credits breakdown with what the mr.
sinister tears means for Wolverine 3 and
other x-men movies click any of these
links here to check those out
thanks for watching and see you next
time you'd be going movie lovers